first of all one person can wreak an
awful lot of havoc there's absolutely no
doubt about that and as we get more
technologically powerful that becomes
even more relevant and important and and
and crucial you know one of the things
that Young said was that we had to wake
up because we are too technologically
powerful to be as morally asleep as we
are and that seems to me just to be
self-evident that's yeah for sure that's
true we're we're we're half asleep with
nuclear bombs
it's not a good idea it's seriously not
a good idea and so well and then you
might ask yourself to you don't well
like what is the ultimate potential of a
fully developed human being and well we
certainly know that you have admiration
for people who are more developed rather
than less developed that's that just
happens automatic or resentment that but
that's okay it's the same thing it
doesn't matter but it's not like you
can't identify them you can identify
them you know and and they're put
forward to you in in in drama and
fiction and all of that constantly so
that's another form of moral intuition
you know you can write you can discern
the wheat from the chaff let's say and
and so the other thing that I was
thinking about that's worth
consideration too is that you know and
maybe this is maybe this is petty but I
don't think it is